nos dicen la gráfica de igual al
logaritmo en base 2 de x se muestra a
continuación
esta es la gráfica en morado y nos piden
que grafique mos y es igual a dos veces
el logaritmo en base 2 de menos x menos
3 pausa el vídeo y al menos piensa cómo
encontrar esta gráfica y espero
idealmente que tengas algo de papel
cuadriculado y puedas trabajar por tu
cuenta
si trabajas en el sitio de khan academy
seguramente te preguntarán cuál de las
siguientes gráficas corresponde a esta
expresión nosotros sólo vamos a esbozar
la pero si está respondiendo una opción
múltiple deberás seleccionar la gráfica
que se parezca más a tu esposo ok vamos
a trabajar juntos primero recordemos que
esta curva en morado es igual a
logaritmo en base 2 de x y lo que quiero
que hagamos es que modifiquemos esta
expresión para pensar cómo se ven las
diferentes gráficas nos mantendremos
transformando esta expresión bueno
primero quiero que gráfica moss que es
igual y empecemos con menos x entonces
vamos a pensar en la gráfica de que es
igual al logaritmo en base 2 de menos x
cómo se ve esa gráfica bueno lo que pase
en un cierto valor de x ahora pasará en
el opuesto de ese valor de x por ejemplo
si x es igual a 4 logaritmo en base 2 de
4 es igualdad 2 y ahora ocurrirá lo
mismo en el negativo de 4 porque el
negativo de menos 4 es 4 el logaritmo en
base 2 de 4 es 2 cuando x es igual a
menos 8 tenemos que el negativo de menos
8 es 8 y logaritmo en base 2 de 8 estrés
y la curva ahora se ve algo así
esencialmente la reflejamos sobre el eje
jeff muy bien ahora sigamos
transformando esta expresión
qué pasa si ahora pensamos en que es
igual a logaritmo en base 2 pero en
lugar de x pensemos en menos x menos 3
como se ve su gráfica como va a cambiar
la gráfica el menos 3
bueno tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos si
estamos pensando en nuestro
desplazamiento porque lo que queremos es
reescribir esto como el logaritmo en
base 2 de menos que multiplica a x + 3
esta expresión es tramposa porque si
queremos reemplazar a x con x + 3
esto es lo mismo que el logaritmo en
base 2 de menos x menos -3 otra forma de
pensarlo es que la gráfica se desplazará
3 a la izquierda y si esto te es
desconocido te encargo que lo revise en
otros vídeos si nos desplazamos 3 a la
izquierda lo que antes pasaba en menos 4
ahora pasa al menos 7 si antes
tendríamos a menos infinito en x igual a
ahora tendremos a menos infinito en x
igual a menos 3
pondré una recta punteada para que nos
guiamos y por lo tanto nuestra nueva
curva se ve algo así
y ya estamos muy cerca porque ahora sólo
nos falta multiplicar por 2 ahora
queremos graficar que es igual a dos
veces el logaritmo en base 2 de menos x
menos 3 que es esta gráfica que tenemos
aquí por 2 cualquier valor que teníamos
antes ahora será el doble donde cruzamos
al eje x sigue siendo el mismo punto
porque 0 por 12 0 donde teníamos 2
anteriormente ahora tenemos dos veces
eso ahora estamos en 4 y por lo tanto
nuestra curva se ve más o menos así y si
tenemos opción múltiple tenemos que
elegir la opción que sea más parecida a
la gráfica que acabamos de esposar y lo
que yo buscaría son estos puntos de
referencia donde antes teníamos el punto
2,4 bueno donde está ahora además
debemos de pensar hacia dónde
a menos infinito antes tendríamos a
menos infinito en x igual a cero ahora
pasa en x igual a menos 3 es todo por
ahora intenta practicar mucho